normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government GOP
Senators call for China travel ban to
prevent mystery illness spread the
Senators wrote to President Biden
demanding he immediately restrict travel
between the US and China okay I mean
that's that's the story right you get
Marco Ruby you get JD Vance you get Rick
Scott you get Tommy tuberville Mike
Brawn you get all these GOP Senators
this is around the same time it was like
it was end of December into January we
started hearing about this mystery
illness back in 2019 to 2020 a lot of
people have been predicting that there
was going to be some kind of lockdown
measure okay and where was that taking
place at that time the the first one
yeah
China
coincidence well here we go man so now
take a look at this what is causing the
white lung oh this is okay remember when
these photos came out of people's lungs
and they were white and now it's like
happening all over again it's kind of
it's kind of wild because you know
basically you I I don't think all of you
in the band but some many of you I think
have stories of defying the lockdowns
the restrictions the mandates MH and so
the day you're like Hey we're going to
come on and we're going to talk about
this we get this story about it's it's
all starting again and now of course
they are saying no no don't worry
there's not going to be another pandemic
Health backs are saying don't worry
about it but that's the other thing they
did when covid first started you had
fouchi saying that you didn't have to
wear masks don't worry it's not that big
a deal YouTube was actually restricting
content was talking about it and then
all of a sudden it turned into the whole
country locking down restrictions on
businesses mandates for for certain
Medical Treatments oh I remember I'm
hoping that we don't go there but hey
welcome to the show guys what what a day
to join us well I couldn't believe it
you you had that up earlier on the
screen I said to you I'm like that's not
from today yeah it's like that happened
today dude yeah so and then we pulled up
the band white long which it was right
yeah I Google searched white long like
apparently there's a band called white
long already they've been around for for
several several years I mean this is
their time to shine baby search
algorithm you know what I'm not going to
live in fear I'm done with it I think a
big part of what happened with Co was
people were afraid and that time in part
of me was like What if this turns into
I'm not even letting my mind go there
this time like I'm right wash your hands
stay healthy be your best self that that
it I was afraid for about 15 seconds and
then I I smelled early on yeah
man it's I mean letting letting letting
like a a scientific technocracy
guide the world is like I'm not you got
a stinky bro on your mic hey stink bug
oh what's happening dude what's he doing
here what you got to you got to Carry's
white lung
dude be careful well hold on those stink
bugs are from China yeah for real
they're a marmorated they were like an
invasive species in the 9s talk about
was that intentional did well they
apparently they arrived in uh 1996 and
Pa I did all this research I was like
where do these come from and how do I
get rid of them and those Lantern flies
I don't aren't those from China too
probably I don't know they're spreading
all over and they're big and they're
nasty and they we have these weird jelly
you you you're not kidding me that bug
is from China there's also that invasive
species in China there's like a wasp
that kills and eats it but out here
there's nothing so it's spreading like
wildfire it's all over buildings also
that one disease Tik Tock have you heard
of it that's from
China that's spreading mind viruses
mainly infects phones well let's let's
let's jump back in time China send that
wasp over I think there's something
about The Temper the
they don't do well and why can we get
our wasp to take care of it but let's
let let's do this like basically we have
this story and I don't know if this goes
anywhere this is it the Myster
mysterious illness they're saying oh no
who knows and I'm you know I think the
price of freedom is eternal vigilance so
we should pay attention to these stories
and uh I don't know what to tell you man
you got to you got to figure out what's
right for you you got to you got to you
got to talk to a medical practitioner
that you trust when these things get get
wild but I do think when it comes to
government authoritarianism is entirely
another question we should just say no
and I hope everybody learned their
lesson from the from the get-go but
let's go back in time and talk about why
you guys are defiant and you know what
is that all about I refuse to wipe down
my groceries this time I don't care what
they say I'm not gonna is that why they
fired you the first time you like
brought in groceries to the studio and
you're like I wiping
them well the first time I was no I just
I didn't want to get the CO shot and I
wasn't afraid of the co shot and
everything I just didn't I didn't like
the message I didn't like the you know
what was sending I didn't you know could
did I think I was going to die from it
no but I I didn't I didn't want to get
it so um and the the company I worked
for was
Disney and they own the TV show so you
on Kimmel yes I was Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy
Kimmel's announcer for 20 years on Jimmy
Kimmel Live wow and um Jimmy wasn't
happy that I wasn't going to get that
vaccine and all the producers of the
show were
very upset with
me but by that time I was living I had
left California and I was living in
Arizona because my kid I brought my kids
there because
uh they uh wanted kids to play with and
Pasadena California was very you know
very tight and very restricted and so we
went there and they had cousins that
lived there so um then Jimmy found out
that I wasn't gonna get the shot and he
was like what the hell are you doing and
then to his
you know in all fairness to him he you
know tried to keep me for as long as he
could and then this you know piece of
paper came in from the Disney and said
all Disney employees have to get the
vaccine and then you know got and I was
in I was actually announcing the show
from my garage in Arizona of a house
that I was would they like send you a
script like in the day and then you'd
read it I would go into my garage and
put on a pair of headphones like this
and fire up computer and I was right in
the control room and they were you know
so it was like 54 oh so like you were
live on the show yeah oh wow yeah oh
that's crazy but they were like even
though you're in your own home n you
can't you're fired no and then all of a
sudden it kind of became important for
me to come back to californ they need we
need you in the studio which wow really
you know maybe they did I you know what
whatever it's their
show but um so you know but once that
came in then it was nothing anybody
could do to keep me on the show and so
Jimmy tried he did I mean I mean yeah I
believe he did I'm not a fan of that guy
that's what was so it's it's a bummer is
it what was so it's um you know like
like me and Adam were really close
friends with Jimmy because 20 years it's
hard you know like so many friends and
friendships were busting up and breaking
up and I I was a victim of that and
there's people in my life that I don't
really care about so much anymore that I
once cared greatly about and said H you
know you've shown your colors you show
show shown me who you are but um it's
hard you know it's the they're close
friendships I I I have to wonder if
they're if if if you're not friends now
were you ever really friends that's what
we say you know like we've had people
who come on this show we have people who
work here and they get texts from people
insulting them and saying I can't be
friends with you and they're like oh
that's and I'm like that person was
never your friend like what did you do
by saying things you've always said and
it's just if these people are more
concerned about fitting in with
strangers yeah than being than caring
for someone they've known for decades
they would never have friend in the
first place well I I agree with you 100%
but then in this instance that never
happened you know so do you know do I
have friends that and this is lifelong
and I'm older than you Tim I've had
friends you know that politically
ideologically we don't think the same
way but before all this Co crap and
before everything that went down that
was okay you know someone told me you
know they were voting for George Bush
and I and you know I was Voting a
different way I was like okay but I I
can still be your friend you know that's
all changed I think Trump changed
everything I don't I think Trump's a
symptom I don't think Trump personally
changed it I think no I think the Trump
era yeah the Trump be is people can't
cannot deal with if you know I'm I'm
kind of you know part of me is glad it
all went down cuz you really get to see
who's evil it's yeah kind of sorts you
know the rotten fruit sort of exposed
itself and it's important not to hate
though CU it's like this dumbass s up
man it's like hate the left and the
right and the this and the them and the
the up and the down and like the and
it's like it's all getting through
social media and they're like did you
see far left this guy's skin color is
this color and this one's this color and
it's like who gives like who cares yeah
but look amen so what I'm what I'm
talking about is I used to be I I was a
huge fan of The Offspring and then I
heard Pete's story and started talking
to Pete and now I am the opposite of
whatever a fan would be I'm a detractor
I don't know an opponent I like their
music their early music it's it is what
it is I'm not going to pretend like all
of a sudden I hate the music right but
you know I grew up listening to this
stuff and then I found out what they had
did and I'm like wow these people are
bad and noodles blocked me he blocked me
too it's not a surprise and I I just
will say it's like a crazy thing just
the first song I ever learned was the
kids aren't all right and then one day
he's blocked me on Twitter and I'm like
wow it's kind of cool you know like like
I learned this guy's song I've never
experienced the pain of noodles blocking
me he still follows you or something I
I'll hug you guys after sounds horrible
how did you get through it we're
survivors I I laughed I I I laughed a
hearty laugh and I was like yo this is
crazy like I grew up playing like I
choose and the kids aren't all right
gone away and now he's this guy's like
gone hyper poitical and blocked me on
Twitter and I never even talked to the
guy I don't even know him but I think it
was around the time that we we started
talking with you and working with you
yeah and then all of a sudden he's like
you're gone yeah you can't associate
with me I'm a terrible person apparently
so I think I think U uh a lot of people
might know your story but a lot might
not do you want to explain like what
went down with you yeah for sure um you
know I I think for for all of us here
anyone in the music industry in in 2021
they r this vaccine out the whole
industry is looking at each other like
all right well how do we get back on the
road how do we get back to making money
because we've bombarded people with fear
for a year or more of like stay in your
home don't Gather in groups don't go
outside don't be in public and now it's
like Well we'd sure like to start
selling tickets again what do we do and
I think you know Live Nation and the the
other people at the top of the pyramid
were like oh how about we'll have the
idea of of the fully vaccinated tour
right so now we can say everyone in the
bands and crew are fully vaccinated so
it's safe for you to come out and come
to the shows again we'll turn the money
spet back on everyone get back out there
and we'll act you know CO's over long as
you go get this shot you're going to be
totally safe and at first I I think it
also trickle down to the audiences too
like the the couple big artists out of
the gate you know for whatever reason
they were like oh we're doing these
shows that are only for the vaccinated
bring your vaccine card you can't get in
without it and I think theyve all
figured out pretty quickly that you know
mandating the vaccine on your abandoned
crew is good for business mandating on
your audience is terrible for business
like they pissed off half of their crowd
because a lot of people did not were not
interested in this or were hanging back
to see how it went didn't want to get
one up front and we're pissed that it
would be segregating them out of being
able to go back out to concerts and
things especially since I mean it was
pretty well known if you were paying
attention that it didn't stop
transmission I mean that the FDA even in
January 21 I have a screenshot of it
that my wife took you know they said
while most vaccines are you know made to
stop the transmission this one was not
tested for that we are hopeful that that
will be the result and you're kind of
like you know I sent that to some of my
very very smart friends and their
response was well I I I don't know
that's weird that doesn't make sense but
I still think everyone should get it so
fall in line or else right so I knew it
was headed my direction and you know so
by summertime we we had just put out a
new record we were gearing up to get
back on and tour like everybody else and
you know I I thought we had to started a
dialogue and there was you know let's
try to figure out a solution here like
I'm I'm not getting this for you know my
own medical reasons and your doctor
advised against it doctor advised
against it and um and didn't didn't
matter I got a out of nowhere I got this
phone call from their manager that was
just insane abusive like
threatening bizarre like you know I'm a
drummer I'm used to kind of getting
treated like crap you're at the bottom
of the food chain of the music industry
right you know who what do you call the
guy that hangs out with musicians a
drummer right so I'm used to crappy
phone calls this was like an
Annihilation it was crazy I got one for
you what do you call a what do you call
a drummer with no girlfriend homeless
there you go so many good ones many good
ones hold on hold on I got one what's
the difference between a moose and the
mighty mighty bossones what is it that
moose has the horns in the front the
in the
back there you go you said something
when you were working on Kimmel Dicky
like and this is right along with what
you're saying that like Disney came in
and they said everyone has to get this
medicine and everything I know about the
medical industry is you go to a doctor
they give you medicine that's tailored
for you they wouldn't say like your
doctor wouldn't say every this I'm going
to prescribe you a medicine for every
human because every human's different so
like it was just shocking in the one
size fits-all thing was part of the you
know what led to me to this is
because you know I have I have children
like what I'm going to take my children
are going to take my you know my elderly
mother's going to take it's all going to
be the same thing my my sister who has
Ms she's going to take the same thing
and and it just that made no sense it's
like how do we know this this guy you
know doesn't eat can't eat gluten his
his joints are better with without
eating gluten this person here you know
is whatever it is allergy
we're all different that's why we have
our own personal Physicians to assess
our own health you know thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net